what is up guys
welcome to the pregame
[Applause]
i do not know what episode we are on but
thank you all for tuning in now if you
haven't like shared or subscribed to our
channel
and you haven't
subscribed and you've watched at least
two of our videos
then
we got beef okay we have beef so you
better start subscribing i am your host
just pearly things
that's correct i've had my change now
you can see i've become a six foot two
handsome black man
okay
so can you please respect my pronouns
for tonight
okay that's all that's all i ask of you
okay um today we'll be talking about
toxic
femininity
now i have some lovely ladies with me
that are gonna um
weigh in and give their opinions on the
toxic
feminist agenda if there is an agenda i
don't know i don't know is there an
agenda i don't know um but before we get
started uh i'm gonna go around to each
one of you gonna tell us your name
your age
and your relationship status
hi my name is tiwa i'm 24 and i'm single
my name is milan sophia i am 24 as well
and i am gracefully single
my name is sophia i'm 21 and i'm also
single
my name's sophie i'm 19 and also single
my name's alexa asme i'm 18 and i'm also
single my name's ananda i'm 21 and i'm
also
single okay so everyone's single today
okay so uh ladies if we get started
right um
toxic femininity do does anyone know
what toxic femininity actually is
i'm going to read it is it the toxic
version of femininity i'm going to read
what
i'm going to read what toxic femininity
is right
the signs to look out for on toxic
femininity is
lion for your own gain
giving misleading advice mocking others
for their their their work or decisions
trying to manipulate situations to make
others look bad the term toxic
femininity refers to the gender
expectations that keep women subservient
quiet and submissive to men's domination
and aggression it also refers to when
women use their gender to obtain certain
privileges it is when
noxus indirect modes of confrontation
are masked with gentleness
do you know anyone that displays these
traits ladies
i mean you see her quite a lot with the
big topic in the moment with the pretty
privilege
thing so i feel like i can see that a
lot of girls using the pretty blubbers
to get into things like clubs yeah
things like that
i don't know if it's necessarily a bad
thing have you never used pretty
privilege i mean i've noticed that i
know it's a difference when you come out
the house with makeup on without makeup
on this is a big difference between the
two
um
how do you use it your advantage i mean
i'm gonna sit here and tell the truth i
have i have before you know like
i think if you can you may as well as
sad as it is
i think like so i used to drive for
example so i was quite about to be there
speaking to the mic sorry
i used to drive so it was quite a bad
speeder and i think if you had a male
police officer compared to a female
police officer there was a big
difference really and i think that could
is anyone else who's pretty privileged
here
be honest ladies
it's fine to be honest
i mean probably but like i can't think
of a time when you know i mean
do you think women get to use that over
men getting to use that pretty privilege
men have enough
oh
what do you mean men having her men have
enough if girls want to i don't know if
they want to
show a guy off their assets to get
something as long as they're not trying
to deceive the person i don't see it as
a problem do you think that's
manipulation or do you think that's just
being like i said if it's nothing bad
coming out of it if it's manipulation
it doesn't really matter do you think it
like
it makes you it gives women like a false
sense of
what they think can happen if you're
just relying on your looks
like they can get you out of a situation
your looks can get us you're thinking if
you're pretty enough yeah yeah yeah i
mean you heard that saying in it when
people are like get your boobs out yeah
yeah get your tits out like
a lot of people's old men used to say
that as a joke and now we say it as a
joke what girls say get your tits out
well i i don't know i've said it in the
past
not to other girls like you know for
what reason for what what what give me
the question [ __ ] people mocking the
old men that used to say it
right
that's interesting
so you you tell you ladies to get but
then no no no no no i don't tell girls
to do that no but like if i'm in a group
of friends we'll be like mocking you'll
be like i'll get your tips out like it
why for what reason because we're
mocking advantage
for the advantage what advantages were
in a sense where you tell someone oh
yeah get your tits out it's like the
idea of sex cells in it so if i want
something
yeah show a little bit of cleavage and
it's like you get you get the little
advantage in the situation so when she
was speaking about the privilege
sometimes it's not done like
um i'm purposely using that pretty
privilege if someone finds you pretty i
feel like they show you a little bit
more of attention or they give you that
little bit more subconsciously i think
that's within general like if a guy is
more handsome than the other he is more
entitled to get a little bit more from
the ladies or
get into a different opportunity or
different doors because of the way
someone looks because because that's
because i've been seeing it a lot that
sometimes you get into a door by just
the way you look rather than before you
because obviously before you even say
anything
when someone sees the way you look they
think you look good they're gonna try
and approach you a bit more
do you think that's fair that you can
get into clubs for free and men can't
i mean it's a ratio isn't it
sometimes when you ask a guy and they
see there's a lot of man inside the club
they're like this is why there's so many
guys in here i mean i feel like the
promoters are just being clever with it
as well because it does bring guys in
having more girls there i mean so
so
you've used your pretty privilege have
you ever been there because this is
we're going to get back to it but it's
this is interesting for me like so have
you so when you use your privilege to an
advantage right you use it too much
you say again you don't really use that
really you don't no not too much all
right do you know women that do you
i mean i feel like people i don't know
specific people but i know that i've
seen it happen do you know what i've
noticed with women yeah
like
do you know what i've noticed
no one ever no one's ever used it but
they know someone that's used it
do you even have it don't even that's a
bit coincidental but like you said
subconsciously yeah like
it just kind of happens sometimes you
don't really think oh i'm doing this now
but it's like just kind of
instinct i don't know i'm pretty sure
it's been proven i swear
like it's like people treating other
people better because of how they look
like the pretty yeah
is that women just taking advantage of
men's men being simple creatures
simple like um one of the guys said they
said that it's not a conscious thing so
sometimes it's more about the effects
rather than the intention going into the
action so i don't sit there and think
okay i know i can do this because i'm
pretty it's i go and do something and
the consequence is different to how it
would be if i wasn't pretty so it's more
about how they react as opposed to how i
go into something
doing so you go into something normal
and then something yeah happens you're
like oh
that only happened because i was dating
yeah so then what kind of psychology is
that put in you what kind of
does that give you confidence does it
like
i mean you don't really think about it
all the time like if it happens it kind
of just happened i'm not going in there
thinking okay i'm pretty this is going
to happen today so it's not really a
confident if i'm coming out knowing i'm
confident what it is already
him doing whatever the situation is
doesn't mean make me more confident if
that makes sense because i wasn't going
to expect that or i wasn't expecting
whether it's been done
but if i'm being honest if i've got a
situation and at the end of the day that
i've evaluated it has happened because
i'm pretty if i go to that same
situation again i'll probably just egg
going a little bit more because i know
what happened
like
it's it's being serious if i know if
i've gone even outside of prettiness if
i've gone to a situation where let's say
my money has helped me get into that
door a little bit more next time i'm
going to put a little bit more down
because i know it's going to get me a
bit further it's just using it it makes
sense it's common sense right yeah in
life you want to use everything you have
to
you know to your advantage so that you
can get to as many opportunities as you
can so if if i'm if someone deems me as
pretty and the reason why i got that a
little bit more is because i'm just
pretty
then we take god and move on
move on
to your situation
it's just that simple there's no point
of trying to hide the situation but i
don't use it if you if someone whether
you don't think you're the prettiest
girl in the world if someone sees that
you're pretty and wants to give you this
little bag for free or they want to do
this take it and just go about your
business
so
okay so do you think that um feeds the
female ego
i mean it must do yeah
for the majority of women i'd say yeah
but some women i guess they don't
actually care at all
to be honest women don't care about
being complimented and being full that
they're pretty there's probably a small
amount of people that don't actually
don't care but a lot of women yeah i
guess i think it comes down to
marginality if you're used to it then
at some point you just you don't really
pay attention to it just doesn't doesn't
really make much difference to you but
maybe if it's like you're not someone
who is you don't really go out a lot or
you're not used to having people
compliment you or treat you this way and
maybe the first few times that it
happens to you like oh actually
maybe you start to look at yourself in a
different perspective but if you're just
used to it then it's like you're just
second nature you don't pay attention to
it what if that second nature is your is
now your reality though do you know what
i mean so it may if if if being
pretty and getting things
just becomes your reality
because you're just used to getting
stuff because you're pretty do you think
that's feeding your ego
i mean that's when i feel like yeah but
that's something then in the future as
you get older obviously you lose your
looks as you get older in it so it's
like if you're expecting that from a
young age as you got older you're gonna
just be disappointed on you so there's a
there's a i've seen a couple of videos
right when you now you say that i've
seen a couple of videos on the internet
where there have been women who have
been young and pretty right and just
been used to the world being their
oyster when they're young and pretty and
as they get older they start to realize
they're being
not looked at as much as me like men
aren't giving them as much attention
um they're not getting the things that
they used to get and so what happens is
now they get quite resentful and they
start saying what the hell is going on
what's going on what's going on and it's
like well your looks only last so long
so i'm just thinking if you are banking
on everything there's probably a certain
amount of time that you can use to use
your looks do you get what i'm saying
and then after that if you've banked on
it once the wrinkles start coming and
the tits start sagging and the bomb
starts sagging
but it's not really a fault of ours
though if if you're in a situation
where everything is just going for
no matter how long it's going for
are you just not going to just
ride the train along until obviously
he's gonna come to a point where you're
gonna have to get off the train but i've
had a good ride but are you smart enough
to know that the train's gonna stop
but that's that's when the situation
comes because when you said when it
becomes a reality sometimes you get so
endorsed into the situation you fall so
deep into the situation where coming out
of it is hard right and that's when we
our own fantasy becomes a fantasy
changes to the actual reality right
because like you said we're all going to
change regardless
so it kind of builds like a full sense
of security for for a certain amount of
time you can't blame the person too much
because that's what's been given to them
at the moment
if if everything is going good for you
you don't even want to think about it
when it starts going bad
i just want to i want to go back to what
you just said you said you when your
fantasy becomes reality right
wouldn't you say that
someone's fantasy is their reality
so like you you've called it a fantasy
but really that's actually their reality
so
when that reality stops where do they go
from there but it's like a temporary
reality yeah that's what i'm saying they
don't realize that that's the thing
they think it's gonna last for life it's
gonna lose your life this is how i
should be treated and when it stops
coming
it's almost like i'm entitled to that
what's wrong with you why are you not
giving it yeah but that's the
unfortunate side effect of that's the
unfortunate yeah symptom of that because
if like it's good to say that i'm now
okay i've got a big ego now but i didn't
give this ego to myself
in a sense where you have fed me this
ego
but you ate it
the meal is nice
the meal is nice but you ate
if auntie now comes and brings you a
good meal you guys you did you did it
even
you didn't need to eat it i was hungry
okay
all right
so the food was there and i ate it but
you're the one that kept feeding me
no i kept relieving i kept on offering
you the food
but at the time i'm hungry
oh so you're hungry for the attention
okay wait hold on hold on speak into the
mic i'm hungry because the opportunity
that you're giving me for my looks or
for how i'm presented yeah so women so
are you saying that women are hungry for
the attention no i'm hungry for the
opportunity you're giving me because you
are because of the attention i've given
so so you're we're saying pretty
privileged so we're saying that i have i
have so i use myself an example i have
built this big ego around me my fantasy
has become my reality because people are
giving me what i want because i look
good
i i'm not saying that i like the
intention i crave for their attention
i'm going by my life i have stepped into
this room and i've gotten a bit more
then
i don't want to bring you into it but
you're the one i see i've got a bit more
than two because i'm prettier than tiwa
it's not my fault that someone has
deemed me pretty until one has given me
a bit more than what they gave teamwork
so i'm not saying that i'm craving their
attention that they're giving me they're
giving it to me
so i'm just going you know what i can
see that it's it's coming for me i'm
succeeding i'm getting what i need from
the situation i'm no one's put a gun to
no one said to tell me you have to do it
to me because i think i'm pretty i
haven't forced you to it's one thing if
i know that i'm here i'll be like why
haven't you why have you gave her this
and you haven't given me this we know
you know that i'm pretty than her that's
a different situation now that i'm going
in like i'm supposed to be getting this
but then that's what brings jealousy
amongst women because if you have a
bunch of women who have all been fed the
pretty privilege all of their life when
you get them in a place and one gets
more than the other one gets they're
looking at them like oh why did she get
that
and 100 yeah that's what i'm saying
if you're giving me everything i want
cause i'm pretty then you blame me
because i like what i'm getting it
doesn't make sense isn't it prevention
are you giving it to me it's gone
prevention you prevent the situation
from happening by stopping you guys
giving pretty girls attention but then
it's prevention
did you hear that guys
stop giving pretty girls attention
yeah that's what ananda says stop giving
pretty girls attention
remember that it doesn't even just
relate to guys
girls do the same thing to pretty girls
as well like in a situation when i see
when some girls see that a girl is
pretty it's like i want to do more with
her than i would do with a girl that's
lesbian that goes to anyone that's how i
feel i don't think i should just men but
then don't i also think girls approached
guys the same way like i've seen people
talk on tick tock how if a guy that
isn't as attractive approaches you in
the middle of the night we'll talk we'll
kind of talk about this yesterday but if
a guy approaches you in the middle of
the night and he's not attractive you're
going to think he's creepy he's a
stalker he's this he's uh
but if an attractive guy happens to
approach you at night time you're going
to be like respectfully for that
there's been cases no but there's been
cases where that's been the case at
night time i'm just trying to get home
pretty i'm not pretty
please really you could be missing out
on your potential husband
why you could talk to me at night
because he's because he's going home too
you're both going home but you might be
in the same place you're a person that
could be a pretty guy and it could be a
potential husband it could be a
potential psychopath but what's more
likely though
who knows you don't know i'm saying
because because it's a situation where
it's just at night time you just don't
know what can happen i feel like if you
if it's daytime that's that that will
apply if it's a daytime if it's an
attractive guy comes to me it's probably
going to get more of my attention than a
person i don't deem attractive but at
nighttime personally for me whether that
is my future husband or not if he's my
future husband you'll find me during the
day
[Music]
anyway have you ladies been listening to
the amber head and johnny depp case
yeah
oh okay go on
no
is this toxic feminine femininity i
believe so the first trial definitely
i believe so is manipulation at his
finest
i've like i feel like she's she just
what she's doing obviously there's
there's always two sides to the story
i'm not saying that she's a complete
liar
but have you heard the tapes i have i
have my mom's watching it she's watching
it live all the time so like she would
always keep me up so i speak in a sense
what i've seen what's happening and it's
um obviously she came up with all of
this by saying that he's done all this
this and that and i'm not saying he's
innocent in the situation but it's using
that
females are you know where victims is is
using that oh yeah
um
i'm smaller than him so he's done this
to me and i couldn't have done anything
to him but it's like once you get to a
point where people are proving you wrong
and you still continue to do it and can
still continue to act a victim that's
just that's psychopath but isn't that
part of toxic femininity don't women get
to be victims
women actually get to be victims when
they're not there it's very easy for a
woman to become a victim that is talked
about femininity because then they put a
person who is a victim to shame yeah
because when i've if i come along and
say that i'm a victim of domestic
violence they're going to be like well
where's the proof
right when you've got other women that's
saying that they are that they're not
victims but they're trying to play a
victim that puts a down shame on
everyone else so that is that is a fine
example of toxicity you're going to say
something amanda sorry are you looking
there no i wasn't no no no no so yeah
have you been watching the case a little
bit a little bit what are you what are
your thoughts yeah victim personality
when she doesn't need to be so then she
don't believe her no
her acting is terrible
it's terrible
it's just i i don't know i just can't
understand it because then for the
actual victims it makes them look like
they're liars because she's not actually
a victim
we had like the first ever male um
female rape charge swear in in sorry if
we had the first ever female in rape
charge not too not too long ago that
popped up on something what a female
when you say that that term could you
say the term grape and not
you put a g before the r okay just for
that
one yeah yeah so we had the first female
group great charge yeah they're good
yeah the other day so obviously that
comes down to toxicity in the case of
like
women believed more than men educate
women why are you putting the g in front
of the
um for for youtube
because you can't say certain things
[Laughter]
otherwise you just get non-monetized you
know what i'm saying
um so so was she convicted
uh i think so yeah first convicted
female that was that was done for that
yeah was not it was literally about two
weeks ago
no so basically being she graped a man
yeah oh
okay and it was like the first bus is
great sorry
yeah so i i didn't hear it but i didn't
hear about that yeah so i've seen that
on something every day so that's the
first time so yeah yeah i was just as
shocked i was like what in this day and
age but
yeah i'm
getting i'm sorry all right um but yeah
i know that i feel like that comes down
to like obviously women
believe in women over men and i don't
know if that comes down to then the
toxic femininity of play in there that
i'm innocent i'm a victim
because when you say when you say
believe in women that was the hashtag
that was going around right believable
women right when
when amber heard
um first came out with the um
with that remember she accused johnny
depp
first of the the abuse right and then
when she did everybody just believed her
do you know what i'm saying everyone
believed her
and
sorry johnny depp lost millions and
millions of dollars in like movie fees
they cut him from certain movies they
want to work with him he got blacklisted
because they believed her
right and so
now it's come out that
you know
potentially she hasn't been convicted
yet or she hasn't been to be found
guilty
that she's lying and most of the people
think she's lying what's going to happen
to her what happens to somebody who
takes advantage
of that type of situation
i personally think they should be given
the same um
punishment as someone who would have
been convicted so i've been domestically
like abusing someone because um so let's
say is domestic abuse or the rape
allegations if i've if i'm to say that
i've been raped i'll accuse someone
forcibly then i should go to jail for
the same amount of time if i if he was
found guilty because not only have i
then put someone's life
money everything on the line
but i'm just i should be able to just go
home and have nothing happen to me i
believe a woman that falsely accuses a
man or anyone for our playing a victim
should be given the same punishment or
consequences as the mind i've gotten if
it was found guilty i agree
makes life so much more difficult for
those women who have gone through those
experiences um
i'm just thinking back to when i was
speaking about the not all men hashtag
um last year and a lot of
people were talking in my comments okay
but there's women who lie but there's
one who lie but there's women who lie
and it's it's really frustrating that
women these days can't share their
stories
without
without the response that okay but women
lie and even though the percentage of
women like the ratio of women lying to
women not lying is vastly different
it's how do we know that it's still it's
been proven um but
what there's been trust me bro
but there's statistics um
but i think yeah it just it definitely
it makes life so much more difficult for
those women but like i said you're
saying
see i'm of the opinion that women are
very good storytellers
right women are very good storytellers
and
um like i said it's very easy for women
to tell a story
right now i'm not saying that there
aren't abusers out there there are
definitely abusers out there but i know
that women will embellish a story
knowing that it's gonna happen
just like we were speaking earlier on
just like women know that they might
have to show um get your tits out to
make people know right when it comes to
stories women like to embellish stories
do you guys say they'd like to make them
a little bit more
saucier than they were because i it's my
personal point of view right that women
have a facade that they don't want
broken down
right women want to be seen as
feminine innocent damsels in distress
when they know in their mind they know
the most toxic crazy thoughts are going
on and they know they may have been in
the wrong but they can't now break that
facade but then i think this hurt you no
i'm not it's not it's not it's got
nothing to do it's got nothing someone
hurting me is to do with experience and
watching the way the world works because
if i was when you ask
that's one of the reasons why women
don't answer the question about um body
count honestly
they don't no generally women don't
because they don't want to break the
facade of being seen a certain way they
want to be seen as
innocent you know i haven't done it a
man will tell you i slept with a
thousand girls
because of the responses we get on men
so because they're like no but the thing
is if you if you're going to be honest
about yourself be honest
if you if you want to con if you're a
confident person right and you and and
you are confident within yourself you
tell the truth it's not all why would
you care about what men think it's not
all girls though
women generally when you're asking their
body account they lie i've never i've
never done that me and me
hang on women hang on women do not lie
about their body characters
why would we feel the need to lie women
always have about their bodies
some men do as well
because not all women are gonna find
this guy that goes and sleeping with
everyone attractive like that's not
that's not cute no women find men that
have slept with more women attractive
women
yes they do
i'll tell you why my personal opinion
i'll tell you why women do not want an
inexperienced man in the bedroom yes or
no does not mean 50 now no i'm saying
no but listen a woman do not want an
inexperienced man you know and i tell
you why women want a man that generally
um i stick with a lot of women because
women when they're attracted to men they
don't go for men that don't know how to
do anything and hang on and aren't
attractive to other women women want the
man
that they're attracted to and five other
women are attracted to also because if
you get that general man if you get that
general run-of-the-mill man ain't no one
looking at that guy you're looking at
the guy that all the other girls are
attracted to
right not you know you're attracted to
the average dude yeah i'm gonna go the
opposite way if i see all the girls
going to one guy saying it puts me off
yeah exactly i'm like he gets hella
girl's ego's probably up here i'm trying
to be away from my way down it puts me
off women generally oh all right do you
uh hmm just stop the cat now right so
stop the gap because women generally
okay so when all right so no i'll tell
you why because the statistics don't
the statistics don't um fare in your
favor because there's a top percentage
of men right when a women are asked the
type of man that they want right for
instance if you go to kevin samuels
right he would ask women generally what
type of man do you want and all the
women generally would ask for a certain
type of man and that man is in the top
percentage of what the general
population of men is so it's known that
women tend to go
for the same type of man that um
that i guess adheres to a certain
percentage the other general men women
aren't looking for
so that's why i say that because when it
comes to the percentage if i was to ask
you all now what type of man do you want
does your man have to be earning a
certain amount does he have to be taller
what's his height um what does his
personality have to be like you'd
probably all have similar men that you
like
the average guy doesn't get a look at it
yeah let's do it okay so if i was to ask
you
what i'm oh this is this this is this is
in the spirit of kevin this is the
spirit of kevin samuels right
so experiment the spirit of kevin
samuels is is you know he's dead but not
gone um so if i was to say okay
how much does a man have to be earning
um
i don't have a number but i've always
said as long as you're financially
stable and you kind of know what you're
going towards that i'm not fine with
that you don't have to be only like 30
40 like i don't have a number to it
because with in this day and age it's a
bit techy but i'm not going to sit with
someone that's at home doing nothing or
got nothing going for them okay so you
want a man that's earning five grand a
year what the [ __ ]
whoa
because because everyone's got a number
that's what i'm trying to say hear me if
you if you say five grand a year depends
on how like i think i'll say like how
you're earning your money and what
you're getting your money if it's
something where you're just starting and
that's what you're earning i can see
where you're going with it because it's
not that's not what it is you're working
towards something no job is paying you
five grand a year name your job that's
paying you five no but i'm saying no
it's not it's not a job you could be on
a job seekers allowance i don't know
yeah but that's not if he's for example
if he's on job seekers allowance my
thing is you're on that for now to try
and sort something out you're not on
that forever
that's my point yeah but but the
question i'm asking is there's a
definitely a minimum that a man has to
be making per year right i've never
actually thought about that
to be honest so i've never all right so
you have to be able so so we know that
you don't want a man that's making five
grand a year i mean i'm not too fussed
if you've got something going for you
like that's not your so you want a broke
man not absolutely
yeah but financially stable we live in
london right mm-hmm so to be quote
financially to
to be quote-unquote financially stable
you need to be earning a certain amount
of money to be quote-unquote financially
stable five grand right okay so it's
above that then right that's what i'm
trying to ask for a number everyone's
acting like they don't know what our
number is i've been so serious
personally i've never fought by people
my thing is if you ever ask me i've
always said as long as you're
financially stable and like you kind of
have something going for you i'm not mad
i'm not mad at it whereas if it's a film
where you're not financially stable
you're not doing anything about it
you're sitting at home and you're
chilling i'm not for that so that's
always been my feeling like i'm not
trying to raise a man either but i need
you to at least have a sense of
something of where you're trying to go
so you have no number in your head about
what i meant personally do you have a
number in your head that i must make
because i'm going to go around and see
if there's a number i don't i don't have
you can be honest i don't have a species
i don't have a specific number i love it
it's just it depends on our future
i don't know i don't have one
what is this
because okay what is this like seriously
okay if i give you a number now i'm
gonna give you a number like over man
like you said percentage that's gonna be
probably the top one percent
wouldn't you wouldn't say it wouldn't
say it but that's not because i'm not
that's not what i need though no but say
it i'm talking about being honest i live
in london i'm thinking about what i make
let's say
if a matching
yeah
they shouldn't talk about breaking the
facade they don't want to break the
facade you don't want to break the
facade
but i can turn up okay let's say just be
honest just be honest i'm thinking if if
we're together
if we're together and we're called we're
in a relationship called like
if if i'm working
because if a man wants me to stay at
home let's say one wants to stay at home
he's always gonna have to make some
a lot more than yeah an average amount
so but if i've asked for a number about
two minutes ago
now you're giving me some kind of meal
number
50k all right cool thank you there you
go
what's up
he's gotta do it
right now chilling like it's 50k 30k
number for a man yeah i actually don't i
don't even know what money i want to be
making in the future i actually have no
clue but that's that's not the question
i asked we're making a lot more that's
not the question that i asked i don't i
don't know what like as long as they're
like chilling they're not starving
like money aren't really a factor
so like yeah we get given the fact that
you really want to be asking our height
um
looks
okay um it's it's those kind of factors
at this current moment in their stage
because they're not they're not thinking
about um
money you're not thinking about money
they're not thinking about security
but when you think about me okay we're a
bit older than not that much older but
they're still young
so it's like the question you're asking
them ideally they'll probably want a guy
that's making a lot of money but at the
moment they they can't really say i want
this man at this time because i'm not
doing that okay so let's go to height
and what's the height of the man that
you i've always said as long as you're
taller than me in hills
so how tall are you i'm five four and
how tall are you in heels probably like
five six five seven so a six foot man i
don't five nine five eight okay five
nine yeah two right um five nine so
anything like five ten five eleven five
ten five nine
yeah the same yeah
yeah like
yeah
no same as me
um i'm five seven so anything taller
than five seven five nine so so you so
basically you want a man that's
genuinely taller than you yeah
so
so when i said so the average man is
probably about five eight it's probably
about us but
about five eight so when i said there
that generally women want the same kind
of man you all want the same type of man
that's about around six foot right
around six foot
because you said you're what five seven
okay you don't have to be six foot to be
taller than me i'll take it
you i can't take a 5 8. ladies you want
you you you kind of want the same man we
don't want this
kind of want the same man
do you want a lady taller than you
i'm okay with that i'm okay with that
it's like you're it's like you're not
okay with saying yeah i want a six-foot
man when that's actually what you want
you want a man
i don't know that's not what i want
i don't want nor do i need i just want i
want someone who's taller than me if
he's six four then six foot yeah
as long as he's taller than me that's
what i find attractive i won't cut you
off because you're not six foot yeah
yeah exactly
with a measuring tape
we're talking about the ideal
you're ideal man yeah yeah yeah yeah
taller than me yeah i'm quite sure so
yeah
why are we saying that six foot six foot
is tall it's not that what i'm saying
but so it's not true
[Laughter]
i keep it consistent
all my exes are six foot six oh
wow that is two that's two yeah
the percentage of men that are six foot
six ain't really there's nothing to find
every single one of them for some reason
what do they find do you find them or
they find you um
either way
yeah do you find them is that is that
because that's your type you what you
find six foot like you find two men
that's your type that's your preference
yeah but it's just because that's all
i've had like that's what i'm used to
right okay well like you don't have to
be six foot six because that's just
ridiculous so you see when you guys you
see when you girls were in school in
college right
did you because i'm still going along
this line do you did you find that there
were certain types of guys within your
college or school that got the girls
sports guys yeah
so
so that's the that's the point i'm
trying to make those types of guys get
the girls
because the girls are attracted to that
type of guy but they're normally trash
anyways that's not what we're talking
about but we're not we're not talking
about that you're bringing in something
else we're talking about the
attractiveness factor men that are like
that sports athlete stuff like that if
you speak to women now they say they
want a baller they'd say they want you
know whatever rapper or whatever please
i'm just saying those are the types of
men that attract women when women go to
uh football games or basketball games
whatever it is those types of guys tend
to find
it's easy for them to get women because
the majority of women
are looking for those types of men i
mean it goes back to sorry to talk let's
go back to what you were saying before
when you said girls kind of go for when
it does go with guys that what kind of
all the girls want right like with the
football guys whatever the the high
profile in it i kind of do kind of agree
with what you're saying with that
because oh so now you agree i'll show
you about a little bit because that
makes sense in it
like it's that way
i actually don't care i'll be down to
the physique because they're sporty so
okay that was that was a little
interesting exercise but if we get back
onto toxic um femininity right there's a
book um called the book this came out
well recently right called how to
destroy a man
now
right what i'm going to do is i'm going
to read because we're talking about the
johnny depp and amber heard thing right
so you can find this book on amazon as a
matter of fact you can find this book on
amazon we can all go now and put how to
destroy a man
now right now
no no now so this is the synopsis of the
book right
how to destroy a man's reputation and
remove him from the power
of such and remove him from power for
misconduct this handbook by dr angela
confidential tells you how
in how to destroy a man
business psychologist angela
confidential x
empowers women with a step-by-step guide
for ruining a man's reputation and
removing him from positions of power
in easy to understand terms the handbook
reveals and explains the fundamental
dynamics between allegations the media
and authority as they relate to male
misconduct in today's society it also
unveils the details
practical real-world methods for
leveraging allegations media and
authorities to dethrone a man
angela confidential has a doctorate in
psychology and is an accomplished
consultant and human resource
professional she brings a valuable blend
of expertise experience and practical
advice in the area of social science
thinking and behavior and allegations of
male misconduct in the workplace and
other contexts
there's a book now
on how to destroy men
respectfully as soon as you said how to
destroy my last switch though yeah
but the fact that that book can exist
yeah i feel like she worded that really
badly though because she's a
psychologist yeah if she's a
psychologist why would she be teaching
girls how to destroy men well you just
see it with amber heard that's what
we're just talking about yeah but she
didn't come up with a book did she no
but
you don't have to amber head may have
read that book i don't know
did you say it just came out
i just
got the book i don't know if it just
came out
um but the book is there
but it
exists
the fact that it exists doesn't matter
particularly why would any girl buy a
book
on how to destroy a man how sad can you
be
yeah
like that you must be i think it's a
very extreme taste i don't think many
people are going to be wanting i it
exists and that's it's not a good thing
it is this but i don't think many people
are gonna be buying so you don't so you
don't
so you don't think do you think that
amber heard case is a singular case do
you think that it's a unique case or do
you think that happens all the time
radical feminists exist there are women
out there who hate all men there are
women out there who kill all men that
doesn't mean everyone's like that yeah
no i'm not saying it we're talking about
we're talking about um toxic feminism
i'm not saying all women are toxic
feminists but i'm saying the fact that
it exists and the fact that the amber
heard case can exist and the fact that a
book can actually be published to show
that how to destroy a man shows that
toxic feminism is alive and well in
society and we don't know as men we
don't know
what woman
is adhering to these type of um
ideologies well until you read the book
surely you can't make a judgment on it
no
the the synopsis tells you exactly what
the book is it's a handbook yeah but
it's not gonna tell you the whole book
as to how to destroy a man
or read the book
well i haven't read the book but the
book the fact that the book exists as to
how to destroy a man it exists also they
put that title in there to like entice
people to buy it it's like click bait
but for books like obviously it's not
going to be you're not obviously going
to destroy a man surely if she's a
psychologist she's not going to be
encouraging that
no well that's what the book is about
you mean
that's not what she's going to be doing
that's exactly what she wrote that's
exactly what amber heard's doing
doesn't mean she read the book i'm not
saying she did read the book i'm saying
that the the behavior exists
the behavior of women destroying men
exists and to say get it though
personally it's not me so that's why i'm
disagreeing no no you're entitled to
disagree but i'm saying
the the way in which you're disagreeing
is very interesting how so because it
sounds like you're dismissing the fact
that there are women out there that are
actually out to destroy men i feel like
oh yeah they obviously are right but at
the same time it makes the people like
good girl good female so you're a good
girl don't say it like that no i'm just
asking are you a good girl
i'm a nice person like i'm not going to
do that so it makes me shocked to know
that there's women out there that
actually do that because then it makes
all the good females
look bad because you're just assuming
[ __ ]
he's just who's assuming you but men
just men are assuming
so the fact that the book exists like i
said and the fact that amber heard case
can exist and the fact that there have
been many men within history that have
been brought down by
sexual allegations sex allegations etc
etc says to me that the uh prevalence of
this type of behavior
is quite
it's increasing
wouldn't you say
when you say toxic feminism is
increasing well i don't personally know
because i don't do it so
i don't i don't know do you not live in
this i live in this world but i also
don't care what other people are doing
with you you only care what you're doing
well you're here for yourself are you
not
right
but i'm saying do you not i do not live
in the world in which we're which we are
going to get consumed by it's just
nonsense
do you don't know any woman that's
manipulated things into her personally
but amber heard yeah
i know there's women out there that do
that but i just don't relate to it cause
i don't do it
so i don't get it
you seem to be getting upset at the fact
that i just landed questioning
are you upset at this line of
questioning well of course because this
is what we're talking about talking
about toxic feminism that's what we're
talking about
what is your question
no no i said the book exists is toxic
feminism right is it on the rise and are
these types of behaviors that women like
amber heard are doing are they also on
the rise
yeah
i personally believe they are
um
and i think social media are stems that
i think if you look at
tick tock but also if you look at um
city girls and all of that culture and
everything please don't come for me um
but i think when you look at all this
hot girl business and whatnot i think
social media does i think a lot of times
it is portrayed as a joke but
there are
um a lot more women coming forward on
social media talking about
hey we should hate men do this to men
this man bye men ooh that's awesome if
you live in the world yeah it's fair
i've seen it but i don't know i can't
relate to it
we're not talking about you relating to
we're just asking if you can
we're speaking about it we're just
speaking about the subject but you can't
say that all women are like that then i
never said that not once in this
conversation but sorry go on alexa go on
youtube but yeah i do i do agree that it
is on the rise um or at least
it's more portrayed in the media um
yeah
because i remember um cardi b saying
that she used to like drug guys and rob
them
do you know what i mean like and if a
guy came out and said you used to drug
girls and rob them that that would be a
whole like
thing
how come she should have been convicted
for that i believe she had been
convicted
because
if it's a crime yeah if it was flipped
the other way around it'll be a whole
big thing where everyone coming under
that what do you mean then like actually
being chased forward more so something
should have been done about especially
the fact that she admitted it something
should have been done about it
a lot of times when um
like like he just literally said it was
a man that came out of that and he said
the same thing
consequences would be different
my mind just went blank
now but i'm saying but i'm so sure
you're saying that
you're saying that there's a double
standard there when it comes to things
like that you're saying that it's like
that
yeah so you're saying that if a man was
to say the same thing
and come out with it
it wouldn't go down well
how do you think it would go down like
it would be a thing where um
it's looked into more
and like they're investigating who it
was what girls maybe then the girls
would then come out and be like yeah it
was me
i got robbed it was me that got drugged
and things like that whereas with her
as far as i'm aware none of the guys
that she claims she's drugged has come
out to be like yeah it was me and i
would like to take this to court or
something along that aspect i feel like
i get where you're coming from in terms
of the aspect because women would buy on
if this was flipped the other way around
they will bite on it quickly they would
and i do get into aspect that some
people might try to buy and even if it
wasn't them to be like yeah it was me
just to kind of that fame or if not the
fame but the money
so in that aspect of things it's like
it's a bit yeah if it was flipped the
other way around i do see how it could
be taken forward and people stepping
forward whereas we've heard no one said
nothing no one came out for anything
everyone's just like yeah it's cool
whatever we move what's the next topic
that's what it felt we're going to keep
down on this but before we get get going
we're going to read some super chats
because we've got some people that have
donated so we're going to see what the
people are saying right um
right here we go let's get some super
chats
i'm gonna get the super chats up for you
um we're also gonna make like some
substitutions get some guys in and see
what they're are we subbing yeah oh
we're subbing
okay
let me know when the super chats are up
um
we're going to get some testosterone in
a place folks apparently
apparently there's too much estrogen um
[Laughter]
if and when you remember i'll just say
again i thought it would
probably be towards the end oh yeah
cardi b
um so super chat's already here super
chat already um guys
have to take a seat um right we got
super chat from jc
ladies other women are trying to keep
you single that's a two that's a two
dollar super chat sentience back
sentience
is just like the the trojan horse like
he's the guy around there
49.99 he said women hide their body
count because men judge women on their
promiscuity which is directly correlated
to their ability to remain loyal and be
good
sorry and be a good bet as a wife or a
mother greater than five hang on ladies
greater than five pair bonding is
greatly impaired
and higher divorce rate sentience again
49.99
i've read guys hold up right hang on i'm
reading these out yeah hang on when host
is reading now we've got to keep quiet
so that we can actually hear what he's
got to say okay sentience 49.99 i've
read the book wow
it tells how to make false accusations
via media and how evidence is
self-corroborated by injecting false
information via multiple sources but my
stance is to allow it to exist so we
know how to defend
against it
that concludes the super chats
that concludes the super chats um also
guys keep the super chats coming in uh
going towards new equipment new cameras
uh we're trying to upgrade the set um
doing amazing work she's out in miami so
make sure you check out the podcast and
her social media what do you mean
pearl's out in miami i'm right here bro
we know we know what we're talking about
i'm right here doppelganger goodness
gracious appreciate all the love guys
and guys thank you for the super chats
we need the money okay we're going to
get a brilliant setup we're going to get
another camera in um thank you for the
super chats um but going back to the
amber head what were you saying now
do you remember no it wasn't me it was
her sorry yeah you were saying you
remembered about cardi b
and i didn't remember i said i would
probably remember the wrong time
oh okay
um so now we got two guys in we're gonna
have to introduce you to you guys right
um what's your name bro my name's ashley
i'm 21
and i am single
my name is coltrane
20 also say it again say that again call
train also 20 well no also but
um
also single all right so guys um since
we've been talking about the amber herd
case
ash
what do you think about amber heard
casey she's a liar man like you could
even tell through the bad acting there
was one tick tock that i saw yeah when
she was like even using excuse that her
dog stepped and stepped on her feet
like what is that
why is that relevant within a court case
you understand but um i feel like she's
trying to use her image as a
it's as mad as a woman to try and go
against um johnny depp
but we're not falling for it i feel like
people so i feel like people walked
about the situation that we're not going
to fall for that easily
yeah
what do you think about uh johnny's okay
have you ever been watching it
i've seen i've seen a couple things
um
i just think you know that's a
representation of a
of a
terrible terrible terrible woman that's
all i can really say on it i haven't
seen too much
on it
yeah
that's really that's how i feel about it
have you have you guys as as guys
because you know the laser spoken have
you guys seen any representations in
your personal life or in someone else's
personal life of what you would call
toxic femininity
gonna go first oh yeah a hundred percent
hundred percent i see people
maybe use you know they're using their
advantage but
to be honest when i was hearing the
conversation
the problem with the toxic masculine the
toxic femininity is that it's a lot of
givens from the men
when you guys do your job as you as you
know like you were saying
we then give that's the problem with it
what do you mean as in to say that we
we we're the ones that that provide the
attention and provide you know when we
go we're talking about clubs when we go
to the club yeah girls ain't paying for
nothing in the clubs right you know what
i'm saying are you saying we are we flew
like are we giving them that opportunity
though
are you feeding the female ego is that
what it is [ __ ] guys are feeding the
female you guys certain there's certain
people that are definitely feeding it
like i mean i don't know me myself i am
feeding
i ain't feeding no woman nothing but
i mean
i mean
but um
yeah man the female ego gets fed a lot
by too many guys that's the problem yeah
but you can't really say that because
you never know it's like you meet him
and now you don't know if you're feeding
my ego or not so you can't really just
you never you're never aware because you
can meet someone and to them like that's
you meeting them and that's them getting
a compliment throughout that week that's
not you feeding their ego no but i know
when i'm feeding someone's ego because
if i'm doing it i'm doing it
how do you know if you don't mind me
asking because if i know cause i'm if
i'm doing it i'm doing it on purpose
doing what exactly though feeding the
eagles yeah but you buy me a drink don't
mean you're feeding me my ego what like
you buy me a drink you buy okay cool
thanks remove what next
all right cool i'm not feeding your ego
on purpose but as in i know it will and
that will be a result of what that my
action will be to buy your drink you
can't say you buy me a drink is
specifically feeding my ego per se okay
because you can't say to me that's a
drink i go out regularly and i get a
drink from people just get me a drink
that's just my normal now so to me
that's not if you get what i'm trying to
come from i don't see that as feeling
the ego and in terms of saying that i
feel like when it comes to female you
don't you can't say you're i get it to a
certain degree yeah you can tell when
you are feeding some but not with all
that's what i'm trying to say
if the roles weren't reversed wouldn't
you feel the same
would you um give me an example so like
if like instead of men moving to women
like you know in the club or whatever
buying them drinks women did that to men
would you not feel an ego boost
of course that's what i'm saying that's
why i feel like it is that not all women
have that but some do get an ego boost
out yeah which is fair enough it's a com
it makes them feel good about themselves
about their opinion so you're saying as
a man if a woman was to buy you a drink
you were getting an ego beast wait hold
on wait wait no no we're talking
the attention that i received from that
i will it will be
it'll be my job to then give an ego
boost back you know i'm trying to say i
think i more meant if it was more like
the norm for girls to do that to guys
instead of guys to do it to girls
so it was acceptable for him to get an
ego boost from a girl buying him drinks
all night or it depends but then that
would that was what she does but the
thing is that would be that would mean a
complete flip of rosin wouldn't it yeah
like i mean if a woman comes to you and
says obviously that's what i'm saying it
depends the way you do it because if you
come you know sweetie me up a little bit
and just saying
you're looking guys because i'm because
then obviously i'm gonna
it's my job to then respond to that in
the in the way that is suitable because
i can't be like oh you know i want to be
like okay nah you know what i see what
you're gonna
what's your drink that you're about to
buy me that's the one that you want all
right let's get two of those but come on
they gotta be on me that's the kind of
way but that's what you're giving us
[Laughter]
it's not really to do with the pride
it's really no it is to be honest
because you think you're setting
yourself down because we're offering you
a drink
speaking
but then now you're saying like because
we've offered you a drink you're like no
don't worry you can't be buying me a
drink i'll buy you one and buy for
myself too no but the delivery is very
important
because i might even let you buy me the
one but then the rest of them i feel
like you are too big especially if i
come to you within your boys i'm like
let me buy you a drink what do you mean
let me buy you a drink yeah do you guys
say you're not going to he's going to be
like nice all right you seem like a
woman now like she seems like the man
and you seem like the woman
that's what it would be like do you know
what i mean if i do that in front of
your boys you're just like nah let's not
do that yeah you're going to want to pat
it as quickly as possible no but let's
okay let's be real a.d if a girl comes
up to us in the club and one of them
says i want to buy you a drink the real
conversation maybe that's what we give
you but if we're talking honestly the
real conversation by the she's really
rather buying me a drink yeah you know
what that means i'm gonna buy her the
next few do you let's go from there
let's be real fair enough that's as real
as it gets though okay so the
conversation i'm having with like or i
know guys would have is oh what you man
want to drink too i might ask if she'd
go and get you some if she's never
happening
let me finish the reason why i'm doing
that is because more so than anything if
a girl's moving to me in a club i'm
confused like yeah this is masculine
energy i'm not on that yeah i think that
i've got this feminine energy that
you've had the courage to approach me
like that's correct so more so i'm like
okay cool like if this is how you're
moving oh let's run game but that's how
far i go but then that's part of the way
she approached you or just approaching
you in general but the thing is there's
a way in which women can let men know
what i'm asking
is it is it her asking you for a drink
or is it the way she's asked you for a
drink it's the way she's asking me for a
drink okay so if i come to like you know
i think you look good
and just a nice and little nice one
sweet tone and second i just i'm gonna
be taking her back because i'm just
asking that's like in what way is that
is it just her asking in general or is
it just
so as sorrow's about to say i think he's
about here it's the way women ask if a
woman a woman in in history have moved
to men but the way a woman would move to
a man is they would she would drop her
handkerchief
and yeah she would look like oh my god i
need help
now if you as a woman don't have the
success to be able to make that happen
or do that then
yo like i'm looking at you i'm thinking
okay like there's a lot of masculine
energy
and this could fester in the future yeah
like in ways that we won't are not we
can't see right men respond to
peacocking right so peacocking is like i
don't have seen a peacock when they
spread their their tails oh [ __ ] yeah
that that's what men respond to
generally and women do that
every day by wearing nice dresses by
wearing shoes by
looking nice by doing their hair right
men see something that looks nice and
they respond to it and then they go
towards it do you get what i'm saying so
we do that in everyday life so if a
woman that's a peacock
comes to a man
is that um
i'm supposed to be doing that right i'm
supposed to be coming up to you that's
just me and maybe it's because
maybe because i'm from a different
generation
with this generation sorry to cut you
off i was about to say with this
generation like especially that now like
women have like they're confident they
don't see it as masculine it's just like
you're taking too long or something
where i genuinely do want to approach
you it's not going to come across like
if i'm approaching i'm not going to come
with a question yo give me your number
it's a bit
it's a bit too much but it's a way where
it would be a softer turn it'd be a
conversation and it wouldn't be more of
a
aggressiveness kind of thing i would
have thought like people are more open
to that nowadays because do you find men
do you find men are more open to women
approaching them later a little bit more
laid back though yeah so they don't know
where to come from the way you're saying
it like is
girls girls are just doing what the
girls are doing and then the man if the
man likes you comes to you but i feel
like nowadays i don't know because when
you go into these spaces on the internet
man are saying oh yeah no like
be a bit more active like come up to me
say something show me something i'll say
i'm in that safe space seeing that so
that i've come to you to come and push
because i've been told i should approach
guys now you're looking at me like we
have to buy my whole my whole team of
jobs
i'll explain that to you so like in the
short term
that is conducive that works women move
into men
like an exchange of attention for sex
essentially
works amazing like it's exactly what the
guy wants long term
that guy is not going to commit to you
let me tell you something about me i
initiated this meant
it's not just that you initiated it's
more so that he didn't pick you
right as a guy it's it's as a leader it
should be that he
chooses you
if if men yeah
i said this yesterday on the show
men will happily have sex with a
masculine woman
happiness
i'm sorry i meant i said a man will have
sex with a hole in the wall anything not
no he's on the other side
right but long term that masculine
energy that woman displayed is going to
be a problem within a relationship
because men don't want to know that
they're in a relationship
with a masculine woman they want a
feminine woman so they want to know that
they chose a woman right
and then she's their woman that they
chose he doesn't want to feel like
yes she chose me so i'm just here
now but however
i think it's very much in your control
if a girl does move to you like you said
a female was into the masculine energy
and a man is into the feminine energy
right but it's your job then to dominate
that then if she does move to you let's
say and that's the situation that's
given it's your job to now then say all
right so you've put maybe you do have a
little bit of your masculine touches
because at the end of the day the girl
you i should be able to submit once you
cause maybe that is your masculine trait
but i'm gonna want you to submit then
once i show you
and once i show you that all right cool
you've done that that's your little
trait all right now babe that's why i
did the i'm gonna buy the drink though
cause then i'm a i'm a mixture i'm going
to turn it into my masculine energy and
what was it it's the it gives you the
ability to then to simmer down now and
go back into your feminine trait that's
what i think
i don't see i i said yesterday i don't
believe that femininity is a switch that
you can turn on and off i believe
femininity is something that you rest in
on on on a on a regular basis just like
i believe that masculine is something
that you rest in on a regular basis
so yeah it's just part of who you are
right so to say that oh i'm gonna be
masculine and then as a woman say i'm
gonna be masculine and then a man to try
and dominate that masculine you're
always gonna have that fight because her
resting energy
is not feminine
her resting energy should be feminine
which means you have less of a battle
that's why i think but surely not all
men care about the masculine energy in a
female well i think that's one of the
reasons why a lot of women don't respect
men nowadays is because men are resting
in their masculine energy and women are
rescuing in a more masculine energy than
the men are
that's what i personally believe i
believe that women are coming through
with the masculine energy and the men
are becoming more feminine which is why
um we we spoke on this podcast um about
a woman not respecting
or hang on not respecting a woman
feeling a certain way if a man acts too
feminine so if a man's constantly crying
or is constant in his emotions women
don't respect that type of man women
respect masculine men cannot respect
effeminate men can i ask a question yeah
go on bro to the girls what are you
doing if you're a man cries
i think it's good
i think it's attractive i want to what
are you doing in that time of moment
though
make him feel better why are you
pointing speaking to the mic
did you know what the joy the better the
better question is though
what conversation are you having with
your girls though after the man crashed
right because
that's the truth that's the truth behind
it okay i will answer your question
because her respect for you has gone a
little bit yeah yeah is it though no
individually you know i speak english
speaking to the mic i'm not
i'm not a very emotional person
so if i if the man i'm with is overly
emotional more emotion than i am
we're not really on the same page but
i'm not putting aside anyone's emotions
because the same way you're saying okay
a man shouldn't cry oh like if he's
crying too much i get that but i'm not
saying if he comes to me christ me
because he's going through something i'm
not running i'm personally not running
to my goals and laughing about it
i'm not doing it because i've seen i've
seen a safe space where i know a couple
that that have that space space and he
has credited to his woman and it's never
been a sense where she's ever gonna run
to it to anyone laughter by all so what
do you think that women respect more
authoritative men
yeah domineering men or they respect
more feminine men
than they do but a dominant man doesn't
mean he can't show emotions no i'm
saying but what what get what gains a
woman's respect it's subjective
and i just did you know so i say what's
interesting is because the reason why
there are leaders in this world right
that people respect is because they
display those traits
um they display authoritative and
domineering traits and those men
generally have the pick of women
because the all women are attracted to
that generally an authoritative
domineering man they may say oh my god
it's toxic masculinity i know that god
that guy's part of patriarchy you know
how many you know how many girls man's
got that i look at that are going for
him because women are attracted to
authoritarian figures women are
attracted to power
but that's part of the attracting that's
part of the attraction
you can be
it's true that's part of the attraction
someone who's dominant but a respectful
one that is there's one that just comes
in and says this is how it's going to be
right
that's nice because because in life
if you go to uni if you go to school
we're taught to respect authority to go
to the police if you go to whoever it is
the presidents the kings
we are told to respect authority and
people that are authoritar authoritative
figures where sh we're told yeah that
those are the people that we should be
respecting and then that power comes
with attract like that power and
authority comes of attractiveness that's
what that's what women generally do
people become disrespectful
and start doing things they're not
supposed to be doing that level respect
goes down
we're told like to respect the police
yeah but when they're doing things that
are
going against what they're supposed to
be doing
you're like i can't respect them but
nine times that tend just bust open this
door right now you'll be silent as a
mouse
because i don't want that to happen to
me right it's not our respective things
exactly exactly yeah yeah that's the
point because you're taught to respect
authority but it's out of fear it's not
out of respect there's a difference from
fearing someone and respecting someone
but regardless
of my husband but regardless you're
going to act in order and i'll never put
my situation around well i have to fit
him because it has to be it'll be a fear
i think there has to be a little bit of
fear
i'll explain why i'll explain why
if you think that you can do anything to
your husband and there's going to be no
repercussions and you don't respect him
so there has to be a little bit of fear
hang on hang on wait wait wait hang on
wait wait yeah but i'm saying but i'm
saying fear has to fear is part of the
authority figure because you fear what
may happen if you cross the line with
that authority figure so i'm saying
that's why it has to be a little bit
afraid just like if you say oh i love my
mom but i feared her when i was granted
because if i crossed the line you should
watch my ass right whatever it is there
has to be a little bit of fear that says
listen if i cross a line to a certain
point i know they're going to be
whatever the repercussion is i'm not
talking about physical repercussion at
all i'm just talking about there has to
be some kind of repercussion to stop you
from crossing that line yeah to make you
think you know what if i do that
ah no you know i don't want to do that
there has to be that kind of thought
within people when it comes to authority
but when when the fear over like is
overcomes the respect when i'm the only
reason i'm listening to you like you
said your mom the only reason don't
listen the only reason i'm listening to
you right now because i fear that you're
going to beat me not because i'm not
because at this point i respect you
it comes to a point when the fear
overcomes the respect that you have for
the for the person then it's they don't
see them as dominant anymore you're just
scared that whatever's going to happen
is going to be severe consequences so
like if i'm with a man or if i get to a
situation of a man i fear that something
like there's more fear to what he's
going to do then i respect him the the
relationship is isn't going to be
okay so so when i say fear i think
people are getting it just so in general
yeah i'm saying like you said i don't
disagree
a man will feel like you said i love my
mom but i fear her because i know that
she's
she's an authoritarian person so she has
she has authority over me as i've grown
up so i know that if i cross this line
there's going to be consequences whether
it is she takes my ipad away or whether
she
takes it no i'm just saying yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah there's a fear yeah
there it is but i'm saying once that
fear becomes more than just the level of
respect that's when we go into dangerous
waters i agree that's one i agree
with the police
of course you're gonna respect because
they have the authority but once it
becomes like you said if they come in
now i'm sitting quiet because i feared
them not because i respect them
so if it so when it comes to
relationships right yeah so people build
bonds with one another right they love
each other right and
you're and if you two have had that
conversation about we're exclusive babe
i love you i want to marry you blah blah
blah the fear now becomes
if i do something
to if i do something way across the line
i will no longer have this relationship
i will no longer have this person in my
life this person will no longer love me
that is a fear so when i say fear fear
has to be part of a relationship to some
degree because if there's no fear then
the person will just do what the hell
they want 100
but then that doesn't cover i feel like
that's a bit separate than the respect
because if i respect for you then i know
that i would i wouldn't want to cross
that line because i respect you because
you are exactly because you're you are
the first person in the situation i
wouldn't expect you enough wouldn't want
to is different than the situation then
coming to handle because wouldn't want
to know what wants to but the situation
in fact
if i hold respect for you if you're dead
yeah
i'm not going to do it to you but
unfortunately
i'm going to do it i've got an analogy
for you
um do you respect
so you respect god and you fear god
what i think you're doing in your
argument is you're using the extremes of
a situation in order to justify your
point
so for example
if you're saying oh
we're talking about uh
having a small bit of fear and you use
the extreme of having a lot of fear for
someone to actually be able to do the
same thing that someone in authority can
do that's an extreme if we're just
talking about
authority in general there has to be a
some sort of fear in order for you to
have respect i totally get what you're
saying you are correcting what you're
saying but more so than anything with
the god analogy you respect god but you
also fear him
do you know what happens
when uh when a person does not fear the
person in the relationship
will and jada
oh
that's what happened yep that's what
we're going back to toxic femininity
right now it's a great segue guys thank
you very much
um
um will and jada
jada pinkett smith took will smith onto
the table talk
and totally made that man look like a
a fool
she said she said to the man i just
wanted to feel good
i just wanted to do this
and i'd and she went there and she sat
in that guy's face with and he had tears
in his eyes yeah and she told the whole
nation no fear of any repercussions from
her husband right
i just had sex with my son's friend
with my son's friend
that's what she done that's what happens
when there's no fear in a relationship
you should call it fear though i don't
think it's fear fear is the wrong word
so what's the what's the right word then
you fear your parents right not you love
them but you fear them because your mum
brought you into this world she can take
you out of it well she can't go
on quote
unquote like it's
empty threats right but you know same
thing and
authoritative figures like police they
can put you in jail but if you're in a
relationship why should i feel the need
to fear you because what are you gonna
do to me leave
i respect you enough yeah but i can
leave if i feel like there is i have to
fear you in order for the relationship
to work i'm gonna leave because someone
else will treat me better it works both
ways you're looking at it i was just
about
men we should also face the situation
like that's why
i don't disagree at all right 100
believe there should be if you both love
each other you fear each other walking
away from you it's not just on the
women's side
i agree it's both ways a man should fear
to lose me if he got out of his way of
doing something dumb especially if
especially if i am that woman that we
say is submissive or you're the dominant
person you have the space to do what you
need to do in this relationship and
you're still doing what you're not
supposed to be doing you should have
that fear that losing a good woman like
me that's the fear of losing not fear of
their reaction but still fear but i
never but the thing is that is fear of
their reaction their reaction is leaving
that's the reaction
like or i don't know treat you bad
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
just talking about it has to be a level
of like you're going somewhere else i'm
just saying there has to be a level of
fear there when it comes to will and
jada yeah there was she just in my
personal point of view from what i could
see she felt like she could just do
anything she was running the set she's
running the whole thing
right because she knows that will is
will you never show here showed examples
that he is never going anywhere they've
said it as well the type of relationship
that they have through the thickest and
the finished
he is not going nowhere he was even
getting he slapped man for it it was he
it wasn't
forever he was even getting that bad
that willow
wrote a letter to pack bro
how
what's going on there's dead at that
point i'm saying
doesn't like rrp but still
how are you letting your daughter write
a letter to another man saying i wish
she was here
that's crazy that's how much she talks
about him and that's what i'm saying
because she doesn't fear whatever
actions that she's on
it doesn't matter
it's not it's so [ __ ] lacks respect so
you know of
but that makes me think that makes me
think what what is will doing is will is
will out here
no but nobody hit this building
but here this is will is out here going
like client another girl
is he doing that i wouldn't put it past
him
yeah that's what i'm saying like
i feel like you come to yourself if
you're taking so much from someone
you're not innocent in a situation
when will smith have those tears in his
eyes right on national international
like tv
sorry
you could see the man was broken he
technically came out and said that he
wasn't crying he was just very tired nah
listen he was
he was
he was a broken man
from a woman in my view who displayed
toxic femininity
like that type of control when you see
oh if you give somebody ultimate power
over you
yeah
a lot of the time
they can take advantage of it
if no one has any fear
of any repercussion
they can take advantage of it and like
you said jada pinkett knows we won't go
in a damn place so if i want to have sex
with his with with our son's friend i'll
have sex with our son's friend if i want
to say certain things he's going to tell
him to go and slap up chris rock
on national tv i'll do that because no
matter what
that mark ain't going nowhere
she knows she's not going anywhere he
she knows that
but anyway before we get we're going to
continue but we need to read some super
chats though guys because people have
been like donating um make another
substitution
go on
oh we did this up
michael fidel
wow
wow michael fidel 99.99 super chat man
um i'm gonna get more drinks i am a
wealthy fit older man in late 50s with a
rotation of young women in the usa
when i want to take a new one in
i can't even just take her
to my hotel without a complete shakedown
she has to be vetted completely
and even then
be careful
he doesn't trust women
melodics to a five dollar super chat
feminism is making it too easy for men
to sleep with women
think about that when you come in with
all that confidence okay david h two
dollar super chat the common pushback
starts with
you don't know
okay i don't know what that was in
reference to
um does that conclude the super chats
there no
uh no i've got two more just loading
them up for you okay
let's load these new super chats hang on
one second
uh
we got some new ones
okay cool courtney harris
two dollar super chat i stole this from
sentience
act natural he's
coming okay okay i get you i get you um
tim the ruth five dollar super chat
there is a saying treat others how you
want to be treated when it comes to a
relationship do you treat the other how
you want to be treated
okay hang on what happened there oh
new one in what happened there
so there was a teleportation went on
literally special moment um introduce
yourself please yeah i'm beth next door
bethany
i run a few businesses bnd visuals 101
teenage fever 101 as well that's me
all right what do you think of what
we're saying who was going on about um
jada all right let me be real
if you want my honest opinion about what
you guys are saying exactly what we want
i would say that we're speaking a lot
about
scenarios
examples of toxic femininity but there's
no solution and i think speaking about a
problem without a solution is an issue
because we're highlighting the problems
but we're not coming to solutions of
them so you have a bag of things to
highlight however
we haven't been given
we have we haven't been given the
questions to solve them problems so i
think a lot of the traits that you were
talking about
toxic femininity
i can't relate to them because i'm not
that because i've changed my mindset so
a lot of these issues that we're dealing
with as women is a mindset problem and
one thing that i was listening to the
podcast yesterday and meditating on my
way here today was that
us as girls have been and men too but
let me speak on the women us as girls
have been indoctrinated from a young age
through magazines from early
to compare each other to other women to
show signs of
lying manipulation towards men
and these things have been ingrained
from young young to the point where you
don't even remember when these were
first put into your mind from time here
all of us probably the girls here
probably from age what 19 over to about
25
from young and tv shows cartoons disney
channels we've been shown how to move as
a woman and the thing is right the world
will tell you how to move because they
want us to be against one another they
want a woman and a man to stand as
opposition when we're not we should be
together so when we're speaking on these
things about toxic femininity i don't
know what i call it's good to highlight
but i think there's a lot of places that
highlight it
um
but but let's solve it
how so wait so what are you trying to
say how
cool cause you got a lot to say we have
to speak on first of all mindset
so a lot of the issues that we were
facing was manipulation and lying
right so you need to fix your mindset
and not be a liar and for everything you
say to a man to be truthful and that's
one way you will what if lying gets you
what you want back of your problems
that's another issue that's manipulation
if you're lying to get what you want
you're manipulating people and you know
you're doing it because you're lying
about it and you are in your own mind so
you know what you're saying
so you're lying to yourself and you're
lying to others to your own gain so
manipulation and lying are the top two
and then the third one i say which you
kept bringing up was jealousy between
other women
and this is what i was saying earlier is
that we've been taught to be jealous of
other women so until you have to tap
into self and realize listen
whatever i don't watch no faces what
other women do is on them but me i'm
gonna be true to me that's when you
change and that's when you see a group
of women changing and within your
friendship groups you can be the change
right so you can speak on things that
you that gossip in yeah me and my
friendship group have been speaking
recently a lot about gossip and
highlighting when we're we're gossiping
to one another about other women you
understand and we've been ingraining
that within our conversations as listen
guys we're gossiping let's finish this
one here switch to the next topic
because you'll be surprised there's
women out here that can see what the
world is pushing they can see all this
toxic femininity and we can see the
toxic masculinity but
again tap into self yeah and follow god
yeah and one thing i can bring on earth
so other people can speak right we'll go
back to the fear and i'll share in my
mind earlier about there's two
definitions of fear so when you say to
fear a man i agree but in what way
because there's the fear of god which is
to be in all majesty god is god bowing
down at the feet of your creator that's
fear right and no man can make you fear
like that that's a different fear so
when you're bringing out the fear of man
it's not the same because men are fallen
and we are not gods yeah so then there's
also another fear which is
um i read it earlier and it was it was
it was a negative sense of fear so it's
the fear of being in trouble it's the
fear of
all the you search up online for
yourselves guys you'll see what fear
means and then you type in fear in a
biblical setting and it's too different
so there's the or of god and there's the
fear of man and the fear of man is that
punishment you know i'm saying uh you
know when you do something wrong there's
going to be repercussions repercussions
yeah so so in what way should i fear a
man because how can i be in awe of a man
because that makes the man my idol and
i'm told to not bow down to no other
idols and then it's like cool let me
stop you right here stop me please would
you say you are in right now you are in
your feminine energy or your masculine
one
right now yeah feminine is your
masculine one i'm in me baby
listen i mean hang on one second one
second one second one second
um
[Music]
you're saying a lot of things right
and you're on your and you're asking
women essentially right
to
not be women this guy was cheeky women
cheeky no no woman not to be a woman no
i i i'll tell you how you're asking a
lot of women how because women see other
women as competition
they do women have always seen other
women as competition because women are
competing for men
right and so if women are competing for
men when you say oh women shouldn't be
jealous they shouldn't be gossiping
you as a woman know that there are women
out there as we spoke about earlier on
today
that they're competing for a certain
type of men right
in competition yeah people try and
uh sabotage their competition people try
and tear down their competition people
try and diminish their competition right
that is part and parcel of the
quote-unquote game what you are asking
women to do is to not now be women and
also ask them to be in their more
masculine energy
so then if women are in their more
masculine energy they no longer compete
for the men that they want and they
start i mean you might as well just let
women be of women then cool let me speak
now
so
when you say competition and all these
things is coming across very
like animalistic that you're comparing
human existence to an animal's existence
where you're animals in animal existence
for some i don't believe that though so
so for in an animalistic experience
right you are competing for males and
males are competing for females same way
or in a different in a different way but
same same example right
but but i believe that we're deeper than
animals and i believe i believe in god
and i believe i have a spirit and i
believe i have a plan so when it comes
to competing why am i competing for
something that i believe god has for me
i don't need to compete what is for me
will be for me so that madness is the
jealousy
that minus is the lion and that minus is
the manipulation and it also well hang
on but what it also does is make you
live in delusion
no because
because because when you say oh if it's
for me it's for me do you know how many
women are single out here right now when
it comes to competing for men that just
say you know what i'm not going to
compete what is for me is for me are
they dead yet hang on hang on
wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait do you know how
many athletes if a athlete just said oh
you know what the competition if it's
for me is for me i'll win no you get to
work and you compete and you go to win
that's what you do when you want to win
you don't just say oh well if it comes
it comes uh
manchester city just won the premier
league the other day right they didn't
just say well you know what if it comes
it comes no there was a cult there they
were competing they had strategies they
knew exactly what they had to do to get
that cup right they knew exactly they
had these it wasn't oh well if it's for
us it's for us guys no that whole that
that's delusion so when it comes to um
when it comes to relationships and when
it comes to uh men male and female it's
actually a competition
which is why
people dress differently which is why
people think which is why people put on
makeup which is why people put on people
spruce themselves up to attract a mate
yeah that's just what we do so all of
this okay i get you you're a spiritual
person you like god all of this kind of
stuff is getting that's fine that's
actually fine but what that's but you
know what there's a lot of single
christian women out there too do you
know what i'm saying and there's a lot
of happily married ones right of course
there are about 70 of the church has
single women there's seventy percent of
the church a single christian women
looking for a man
so sorry gone i see what's going on here
obviously
beth has come here
on her boss lady are we out you know
that's just what we got here in it but
no no fortunately for yourself that's
what you are and we can all clap for
that today
in fact we should and i will but
unfortunately though the world that we
live in generally the majorities that
we're talking about are not of that and
you're in your boss lady in your own
right so we're talking about the general
consensus of women that are not reaching
on the things and then the generals on
are in the in the the the numbers that
we're talking about here and the
percentages that we're talking about
here because you know it
is right and i'm one of you you do that
but majority of women they they know
that in a competition beth i'll be
honest with you that's this you're
talking facts i hear that but but ain't
they real well
but mostly but most people don't know
hear me hear me out most girls know that
in the game they want to win
you understand
i can't lie
i'll be real with you
the most people most people that have
that kind of that that think that kind
of way well like my way
the kind of way that you that you have
as well kind of have as well i'll be
real of y'all and i don't want to offend
you in a kind of way
they're still single okay and
they'll they will they will get older
and older and older and when you get
older and older you you lose um what's
the word sexual value
and you realize you're in a game and
then and then you realize late on you're
losing this i hate
but i don't lose
that's
what i'm talking about guys
this is what i'm talking about like
delusional behavior because the thing is
i'm not saying that what you're saying
doesn't make sense that's not what i'm
saying i'm saying when you look at the
when you look at the wider the wider
world in which you live in yeah it's not
the way beth sees it right so hang on
hang on so the way beth sees it is the
way beth sees it and i get beth see beth
is her own individual and she moves by
her own rules and she does her own thing
i totally get that but when you step out
into the real world it ain't like that
right what it is is a competition so
women like like like i said women like
you they stay single for a long time and
then they realize oh you know what i'm
in a competition
actually and it's too late because the
competition that while i was saying oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna manifest it or i'm
just gonna be me and no there's a
competition going on out here
i hear you
you work to an extent we're all in
competition you work to you work for
towards a relationship or whatever with
a man to an extent and then you say
whatever god has planned for me has
planned for me it's like after you put
in the work and you realize okay it's
not working you kind of let life come to
you
i think you men will be surprised where
cool i've come with this my intro
however when it comes to relationships
right i have no issue with yesterday's
topic submitting to a man cool
maybe surprising from my intro but i
don't have an issue with that so i think
that
you have no problem submitting to a man
i think that
i will find problems because of the way
i've been raised and the environment
that i'm in that i will find problems
with it
friends that you surround yourself you
don't think you display masculine energy
let me ask you a question everything no
i'm just asking
masculine energy you tell me because
me i'm not i think you are just playing
very masculine question
how
how would what would you well okay so
what she's done i just this is
educational purposes okay so
first of all
so first of all dress in masculine
first of all the second of all the slang
uh third of all uh the way in which
you're trying to take over a
conversation when there are men in the
room uh for fourth of all
um
i'm just being real
i'm just i'm just being real so the
thing is i'm not saying that you don't
have something to say
and i and i respect every human being
that has something to say but i'm saying
there must also be a self a sense of
self reflection when we're speaking and
when we are actually doing what we're
doing i understand that when i speak
yeah people may say you know what this
guy is in his energy and he's done this
and the thing is i'm actually aware of
that but if you think if you're doing
what you're doing and you don't think
that you are in masculine energy then i
would say there needs to be a little bit
of self-reflection going on cool so i
didn't i didn't get to speak on if i
think i'm in my masculine energy or not
i think the top three things you listed
was
so cool number one appearance right
i don't know if that was your number one
i think that might have been your number
two the way i see it
so cool the way i dress is intentional
because of what we're speaking about
earlier about pretty privilege best
believe if i dress a certain way and i i
move a certain way
you'll very much feel that energy of me
but i choose not to happen see i've seen
you taffy
because like this
i feel like one i'm more hurt and i'm
more hurt
by men yeah and women because women love
a masculine energy so even around women
i know they're listening to me
so is it intentional
possibly not possibly not i was raised
with a lot of males around me so
you kind of
take on what you're around but it's not
intentional it's just it ends up being
what it is what's the other thing the
other two things you said um
i remember you said about it
so the slang that's just where i'm from
and to be fair sign i've been working on
but it's not really
for anyone other than myself because i
want to speak better
and to be fair i can cancel it out you
know and i can just speak without the
slang so with the slang thing it's not a
masculine energy it's just what i've
been around and i know enough females
that speak like this and they're very
feminine
and the third thing you said was what
you want to um
i don't
trust me you watch me sit here in peace
and listen me
my people know me i'm a good listener
and i will listen
which is a very good point though i
don't have issue with that so with the
with the feminine masculine energy i was
i was thinking about when i was sitting
so you don't think that you have
masculine energy i don't i feel like
everyone has both so masculine
what am i resting in yeah what one do
you think you're wrestling right now
i would hope somewhere in the middle
i i will just say
at one point in your statement you did
say you were in your masculine all right
cool thank you thank you for reminding
me of my words that's important
but i wanna okay cool am i resting on my
skin
yo talk to me a.d
it's not a problem yes
i think if you said it was a smile on
your face but if i think if you said
this especially with a smile on your
face and your tone a bit um
like you said as well yeah just like you
said the slang terms that you were
talking about but you said but english
only one the people that you are raised
around in there and
what you also did say that they're men
so you may not even unders
and i know i know you say and it's i
think what the difference is is that
because you're so comfortable in
yourself that's where it doesn't feel
for you it doesn't matter
the facts are the facts is basically
what he's trying to say it's important
to know that we're not saying it's a bad
thing it's more so than that
saying you're not maybe you're not aware
of it
so hang on a minute hang on one second
one
the
second
in here
right the guys in here yeah sure know
for a fact
that a woman the way
displaying herself like you they know is
trouble it's trouble
no because of the masculine energy it's
just being and i'm just being honest
like if we're not gonna be honest we're
just we have to be honest
because like like he was saying the
masculine frame the masculine energy the
masculine words the masculine sense of
of self
right is going to be a combat listen let
me let me say something a man does not
want to have combat with his woman or
with a woman he doesn't want it he wants
peace from a woman all right
so if
right we all want peace
so imagine so imagine i've got masculine
engineer and this thing is so funny
because we're talking about toxic
femininity and i feel and i feel like
toxic femininity breeds masculine women
and breeds feminine men that's what i
personally believe 100 right
i believe toxic
feminists i don't think the way i am is
because of toxic males because i'll be
real with myself the males i've been
around so my older brothers my father my
uncles
i would say
fruit and analysis are a more grown age
they are good men they i think everyone
struggles with their toxic side because
that's just what sin is it's the
darkness in you but i think overall
things i've learned
is through good men so it's not even
like i've been raised by some toxic
man
but what i have learned through i'm not
saying
i'm not saying you've been raised by
toxic men not cool i'm saying you've
been raised around masculine masculinity
very masculine men right you've been
raised so that's the same but if you've
been toxic
but hang on but just imagine right i'm a
man
and i've been raised around
feminine women yeah right all of my life
do you think that it would seep into my
energy if that's what i'm constantly
around it would it would make me right
exactly which which is what i'm saying
which is what's happened with you it's
clearly right so what i'm trying to say
is i'm not saying it's a good or bad
thing right i'm saying that if you were
to analyze a man and i was here like
hang on a minute
where's that guy been raised around
right right you'd ask that question so
the thing is it happens with women also
this might change i might not change the
narrative but i also went to an
all-girls school and i have a mom and i
have aunties right so it's like i've
equally been around good female energy
but maybe what i've chosen to adopt
at this age anyways especially with the
things that i'm doing right now
is i find that
portray it's not even it's not i'll be
real it's not intentional what how i
come across i'm not thinking to myself
cool let me sit on here and let me come
with my masculine energy let me check my
[ __ ] this is that means that means it's
a it's it's a ingrained it's ingrained
right it's natural so that's one of my
points a woman with a naturally
ingrained masculine energy yeah there's
an issue is an issue for men defaults
if that's your default setting
it's an issue for me i'll be wrong
this is a travesty what's just happened
because it works i have to be honest
i have to be honest right i'm glad this
is coming like a therapy
yo guys if you want a therapy session
from pearl right if you want a therapy
session from pearl we charge five
hundred dollars an hour okay one to one
they are if you want them they're ready
so i'll be real i think so i can speak
on my previous relationship right it was
three years long and i'll be real
and i hope he's not watching yeah but
i'll be real me in that relationship
come like the man
surprise surprise all right who broke up
with who i broke up with him but then
you're surprised surprised like you
weren't man
then before your previous man's point
i'm not afraid to prove it but this is
this is where we return back to the
initial point
this is what we spoke about yesterday
okay
we said if a woman is resting in her
masculine energy right
if a woman is resting in her masculine
energy it is a problem for a man and
it's going to be
a combat situation for a man and men
generally and you're probably going to
think like you said this guy is not
quote-unquote man enough right but you
have to understand that men
do not want to battle with women they
don't they and women should not want to
battle with men either that's that's not
what it should be we should be out here
complimenting one another
so let me just let me just kind of flip
something right and something that i've
noticed within this within this um world
at the moment right guys um
sorry i can't hear um so uh
within this world at the moment women
are allowed you see you as a woman right
yes hang on you see you as a woman
you can be in your masculine energy and
you can get into a confrontation with a
man
right
and if you're in a confrontation with a
man
a man knows one way to deal with
confrontation
and that's with confrontation
right but you're a woman
and then that's why and then so and so
that's why
a lot of women are allowed in this
society to be all up in a man's face
pointing up in his face shouting up in
his face right and men have to be like
i'm not trying to be a puss
right but
in this situation i'm going to have to
be because i cannot combat this
situation
because you're still a woman so women
should not should understand don't
combat a man that way because men know
only one way to deal with combat but if
men know if i do that to you right it's
going to be a whole problem he's going
to go to the police are going to be
called right the authorities are going
to get him it's going to be but if it
was a man if two moment and he done that
to a man it would be it will be a fight
so if someone comes to you on an
argument way the first thing you're
going to do is slap them no i'm saying
no i'll explain why as men
we understand we've grown up with
confrontation all of our lives from the
playground we've had fights do you know
what i mean being the master
it's a masculine trait so we so when we
get a certain energy that comes towards
us we know exactly what that means we
know exactly where it can turn out we
know exactly what the end of the road
can be right because we've dealt with
that all of our lives when a woman comes
with that same energy that we understand
as men yeah we can't deal with it the
same way that we're supposed to deal
with it so what we're supposed to do is
walk away and a lot of the time women
when they see a man walk away they think
that he's an idiot
it's not that men have chosen not to
deal with you in the way to deal with a
man because they know that at the end of
the road is the police and the court
system but let me ask you a question are
you gonna argue if you're gonna he's
gonna end up in a like in a violent
situation yeah but a man's okay with him
okay with that with another man but let
me say
does it make if you're having a
conversation with someone and you're
able to walk away from another man or if
he turns around and says yeah this man's
a [ __ ] from walking away because as a
man will you get called a [ __ ] by
anyone no no because a man being called
a [ __ ] from a man is actually part and
parcel of the confrontation and man
being listen you don't understand man
listen
hang on
around and stop another man because he
got told he's a [ __ ] right right but
the thing is
that's what i'm trying to say exactly
hang on hang on that's part of the
confrontation because men know how to
when men do that it's a different one
out if a woman calls a man and says man
up you
know what i'm saying
there's a difference in a man-to-man
argument
me saying to a.d about your [ __ ] it's
me saying go on then yeah you're
provoking me call me a [ __ ] argument
now you're not saying go and then hit me
though that's not what you're saying you
rising that you're using the masculine
traits that you have but not asking me
to respond in a way
the same way it's finished
but equally
as confrontation is false okay but
that's what that's but that's uh
smart man knows when to walk away of
course of course how do you know what
what i'm smart man let's put it back
because if you're going to fight back on
topic one more time one more time one
time the person you come across and
arguing you're going to find yourself in
a job so okay
but listen but listen a smart man no
decision so what a smart mom would do
that's an emotional decision so a smart
man the cool decision is to walk away in
a situation that you know is gonna get
you in a sticky one so a smart man is
not so before then a smart man who yes a
smart man will not get himself in a
situation but we're now talking about
we're in the situation now there is one
that
a smart man will not get himself in the
situation but once you're in this
situation once you're calling out those
things you either
from a smart man from early will not let
it get to him let another man call him
calling him a [ __ ] regardless if you
know if if you get to that situation
where cool you've got into the company
yeah it's happened i won't say it's
never going to happen it's happening
but even within that situation you have
to be smart about your moves i mean
right
women a lot of women don't understand
the way men are like and you're talking
from this vice versa but the thing is no
blood things you're talking about wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're talking you're talking
hang on you're talking from the aspect
you're talking from the psychology and i
get it you're talking from the woman's
perspective right i'm telling you from a
man's perspective and then men are
telling you from here from their
perspective they understand what
confrontation is right and they
understand that verbal words between men
can so if he's using the word [ __ ] it
can turn right into another vision
they can turn into a physical yeah if a
woman tells this man the exact same
thing he knows he can't even deal with
the situation the way he would because
he knows that it would turn out in the
worst way for him so that's what i'm
saying when it comes to that you know
i'm saying when it comes to women doing
that to men
women tend to understand now a lot of
women tend to understand due to toxic
femininity that they can actually
because if you go back to the amber herd
case we were saying she was saying that
to him man up what's wrong with you i
just hit you what's wrong with you
and he's thinking ah if i do with this
i'm sure he's thinking if i do with this
to where a man does deals with it right
he's finished and men know that and the
thing is women know that too so they use
that to their voice let me ask you
something hold on just hang on one
second before we keep going we need to
be super chat though we need to be the
superstar
but we're gonna get back we're going to
get back remember it yeah hold the foot
no hold the foot please hold the foot um
right
there we go
okay
so we have a super chat from tin the
ruth 10 super chat also this woman
didn't read the bible the bible says the
opposite
what she's spouting the bible says the
opposite of what she's about and the
bible says that a woman is a caretaker
and a follower and a manager protector
on the provider um yeah but she did hang
we need to get through all the super
chats
in an orderly manner in order for the uh
show to flow so yeah allow
boss
right we got from boss five pound super
chat i've never heard someone say so
much but communicate so little the girl
in the middle is word vomit all day
well tim the roof 20 super chat says so
anyone know the fact that this new gal
is going to be single till she dies
she's not listening not understanding
and rude get off the stage dear it's
humiliating wow um people painting
this is right
jacob mckenzie five dollar super chat
the truth is hard to hear sometimes and
pearl
quote unquote be dropping truth bombs as
usual um tim neruth
20 super chat god has a plan for you if
you follow the signs for his path and he
puts
and he puts it in front of you
you can't just be born and do anything
and say god had a plan for you tim the
roof again ten dollars the most loudest
person in the room is a fool in the room
and if you think being loud is
intelligent you're wrong the smartest
person is whom is silent and listen this
lady is delusional
tim the ruth again ten dollars how much
super chats do i have to keep sending to
make this woman get off the stage and go
back to her room and learn a thing or
two wow i'll keep sending these
wow courtney harris ten dollars a lot of
women don't understand that we are
animals you can't think of yourself out
of out of the food chain where as we
hang on we are as predictable as animals
in nature in fact we may study animal
behavior to learn about our own
interesting jc hang on wait wait we
still got more jc two dollars girl in
the middle's favorite position is amazon
style
what does that mean i i don't i don't
even know someone tell me i don't even
know what that means um boss is a five
pound super chat notice how the show was
more peaceful with the white girls some
black women are so disagreeable
wow i don't know
i don't know i don't know
let me just keep reading um tim the roof
twenty dollars i wish i was on this show
i'd explain all the facts so and i think
i'll explain all her facts are so wrong
to bad i live in the united it's too bad
i live in the united states of america
you're lucky i'm in the best country in
the world better believe also sin is the
bad choices that you make
last super chat david h five dollars
a man should know when to walk away a
woman should know he may not
that's how mutual respect is established
we're not finished oh we got more yeah
tim though thank you for the bread
he said he paid for the hate but i hate
boy type two dollars even chester got a
better take on her life than this one
um
he said even chess has got a better take
on her life than this one she's just
chester's one of them she wasn't she was
another guest on the show um niji miller
10 super chat to the women would you be
willing to deal with the way men deal
with issues
with the option that yao could be
brawling 10 minutes later
i think that concludes the super chats
all right let me say something to tim
thank you for the bread i appreciate it
um
i don't act like it's going to you
it's not in it but it's going to the
community yeah it's going to it's going
to pearl it's going to equip
tell me
this is the way it is yeah tell me i
think yeah
see you guys contrary to this whole kind
of conversation as it is this is where i
refer back to the first kind of first
points that i was making you see that
situation when a girl comes to you in
the club and
it's really depending on how masculine
you are you can overtake a masculine
energy and then quickly let us simmer
maybe that is even in that girl's
that's my natural but as if you are the
superman
if you are the superman that we hope to
be hope to be and aim to be you can
ability have the ability to simmer down
well basically what i'm basically trying
to say is that
from whatever beliefs are out there even
about what beth's persona that she's
bringing on today
the only thing that is because you
the one thing i can i can never throw
away is that the attitude and the
abilities that she's got to speak
is what is a leader at the end of the
day and that's a masculine trait that
we're talking about but this is someone
that is going to lead the nation one day
right
all she needs though is a super
masculine man to overtake them i don't
wait that's jeremy james
the co-trainer i'll be honest with you
bro
you're my guy yeah
are you going to disagree with me no i'm
going to disagree because let me tell
you something
if you're gonna disagree if you're gonna
disagree let me finish my point here
the point that i'm making is that
for someone then the oh because this is
just it's just a statement and you i
don't think it's a really a disagreeable
thing the same way how the girls agreed
when someone comes up to you in the club
the only thing to do then is to then
show your masculine energy and overtake
that beth in the same energy needs
another another masculine man that's
going to as much as whatever level it
may be needs someone that is going to
and to be honest that's what she's got
exactly
and because i live and she will and
that's what that's the only thing that
she would get maybe it's the minority
but her minority it may even be on top
of the even one percent that the
generals are looking for but it's on a
it's on a zero point zero one because
it's a superman
but cauldron i'll tell you one thing bro
two masculines don't make a right bro
i've even had this conversation
yesterday with um
yesterday yesterday bro two musketeers
don't make a right why why why should i
i have to
fight you right i understand that don't
that don't work hold on
hold on
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on hold on because
beth will submit to the right guy no but
hold on beth will submit the right guy
and i said that from the beginning
see certain man certain man that will
not submit to you and that's unfortunate
and even maybe the a lot of the the
percentages that we're talking about men
may a lot of men will not even take it
however a superman
a superman will be able to because
you look listen listen bro but g veggies
jeremy wait lemme speak coaching how
long should you have to wait it miss
minori
how long she has to wait what do you
mean wait that's one of our own timings
i ain't waiting for them i hear that i
hear that but i'm gonna let them duke it
but if you know if you know it's
minority
yeah
you know that's not that much so hold on
so if you know that's less
cool you know the majority i want to
handle done hold on you see that we use
the example before back in the club
right man moves to a girl moves to a man
in the club right
are you able to do you think if a girl
moves to a club and says let me buy a
drink are you able to maneuver and still
be masculine yeah okay okay
so there is a there is a general scale
of men that are able to do that right
some men might you know what he did
which in my personal opinions like you
were saying i think that's that was a
feminine thing that you were saying to
say that to say that um when a girl
comes up to you and say ah let me buy
you a drink you say to the mandem what
amanda do you want to drink as well i
think that's feminine in my opinion in
it but to say that because
what is a girl's job to be it maybe
because whatever intentions that she had
to do that she didn't intend to buy the
mandem drinks okay you may have you may
have
stuck there to do that okay nah you
gotta use your masculine energy let me
ask you a question this superman you're
talking about where where is he
me personally i don't know i don't know
what's in there but me personally i'm
i'm able to do that me personally okay
you're the superman
however i know the abilities that i have
to tell us to tell a woman in her even
in her masculinity to yo
this ain't the time for you to be
masculine and that's the ma that's the
person that she needs in her thing let
me let me get this right you think me
running game is feminine
no no no but that's what i'm saying when
we talked about the intention it was
just the initiative to just go and talk
to a man about and say i want to buy a
drink let's be honest same way a girl
will back out the wallet and a bit on a
date and say i'm splitting she ain't got
no intention to pay in that same way if
a girl comes up to you and says yo let
me buy you a drink you ain't got no
intention she was just opening up a
conversation let me get this right go on
if a girl comes up to me and says let me
buy you a drink she has no intention she
has an intention to talk to you so she
has an intention she has an intention to
talk to you of course but not to buy you
the drink though that's what i'm trying
to say
you've just said yeah it's it's the
intention right the intention of trying
to get a conversation out of you so then
me calling her bluff which is
essentially what i'm doing by saying yo
madam let's see if she's going to buy a
stream yeah
am i not calling her bluff you are yeah
you are exactly what you said is that
but i think that's feminine yes
in fact let's open up to the girls girls
what do you think as girls here if you
ask a guy let me buy you a drink and he
actually does that and says to the man
them let me buy a drink is that
masculine or feminine you guys answer
this let the girls answer if they leave
so tell me sorry i'm asking a man
alright cool let me buy you a drink and
then he's gone to his boys you look like
you would do that though for real though
let me get my feminine energy
so if a guy comes up to me and asks me
for a drink
and his and he asked his boy's tea
is that feminine energy wow
let me ponder this one
does anyone else have to speak before
election lessons and also so obviously i
don't i don't want to come across too
masculine so if anyone wants to speak
before me i'll happily speak closely
let's really open up the question though
let's read it you speak the way you want
to speak okay then let me talk in it so
if i'm asking a man
let me buy you a drink yeah
yeah and then he's going to first of all
you don't know
you see drinks these days kind of
expensive so i'm i'm buying you a 10
pound drink you've got four man with you
the bill now comes to 60 pounds hey
no please i buy you a drink and just you
you see you sir with their headphones on
i'm not buying your boys a drink best
believe
is that feminine energy though to be
like oh okay cool my boys want to drink
too
i see the point because it's like girls
will be like oh my girl's on a drink too
100 i've been there i've done it
exactly so girls will do it the girls
will do it
now it's such an anomaly for a girl to
buy you a drink that if you now come on
box for your amanda for a drink as well
it's like
you're pushing what are you
i want to go back to this whole superman
idea that you have right
um because i think it's very interesting
that um
i think it's interesting this superman
so you're saying right what you said
before
is that there has to be when you have a
masculine woman yeah
there has to be a
type of
superman yeah to put her in her feminine
is what you're trying to say yeah so
like i said
men
do not want to battle with women
we battle with men like i was saying we
ba we're men we battle with men
we shouldn't be battling with women
someone's you know i'm saying hang on
hang on wait wait so we shouldn't be
battling with women and the fact that a
man would want to take on a battle
from a woman
says to me that he's not ready to take
on a battle from a man
and the reason why it says that is
because the real battle as men is with
men
you don't battle women if a woman is
combative and she's masculine leave her
to the side because that's not what hang
on because that's not the battle that
men need to be taken on men take on
battles from other
women
sorry other men sorry they don't take on
battles from women and if a man thinks
oh you know what i'm going to battle
this woman because she's too masculine
and i'm going to dominate her no men
wanna bro i'm just saying
the battle for men
is amongst other men but this is the
thing that i was
saying what i was in my point is that
isn't the fact of the battle it's the
fact that in the even because let's be
honest as a female it is not her natural
to be of in her masculine energies is
that something that we can agree on well
it's natural it's natural
right
i'm a girl you know i might call her
she said she just said she's basically
said that she is because of her because
of her upbringing right right but not
from when she was born that's not how
she was from what it would have been her
if there was none of that came right she
is a girl she is a girl she is a girl
and that is that is the fact yeah she's
a woman
is not naturally in her masculine
energies because she's a girl she's
naturally in her feminine energy right
what no what okay no no she's already
said she's naturally in her masculine no
no but i'm saying i'm saying no i'm not
saying what she is but i'm saying you're
saying
nature aesthetically
she's a woman yeah i get you yeah so
the things that she still as a as a as a
female attracted to men as well the
things that she's attracted to you are
still the same things that other women
are attracted to 100 percent yeah so
still as may whatever the level of that
level still being
as m and that's what i was going to say
to you i'm not trying to battle the
difference between the supermarket is a
battle she will know from the sense from
the time same way another woman will
know that doesn't i'm not gonna battle
with she will know when it is superman
yeah i'm not battling it doesn't matter
you might say that to fight that you
have to battle and that's because maybe
you feel like you for the only way for
you to actually challenge this is the
battle i know me personally i'm not
battling that but still beth will
conform
i'm saying that men
if you're what you're saying is you got
too much time on your hands for me
yeah because hang away
wait wait wait wait wait narrative
wait wait wait the reason why
is because
my battle
as soon as i step out the door
not even just
me being a man my battle is as soon as i
step out the door i got a lot of things
to battle as a man do you know what i'm
saying and you do too
and even to being a black man
you have a lot of things to battle when
you step out that door of course trust
me my brother yeah when you get back in
the house and the door that you stepped
out of the one thing you don't want
is after battling outside to have a
battle inside what is my because i'm
telling you bro it will take its toll on
you as a man you do not need a woman
inside the house to be battling with
when you've just battled the whole world
outside because your house is not always
trying to become no but the thing is no
but a woman a woman hang on but a woman
in her feminine a woman in her masculine
is easier to handle
i'm saying that the aura the level of
super that you have to be is still on
it's on the same it's on the same
spectrum as a super feminine woman yeah
a man that battles the rest of the world
we don't need super feminine family
women super just talking about the
spectrums right whatever spectrum that
you're on
uh the the more feminine you are you
don't have to battle it means you have
to battle less right still so the more
masculine you are technically right
still means no matter what level her
masculinity is on still if it is
dominant enough it will still not be a
battle
it's too it's too much work it's too
much work
if it's too much
you're hoping that see that's it's
different when it's work only if it's
not who you are it's only work but you
see me my aura why is your work going
because you've got time you know what
i'm saying it's work for you but i'm in
my whole position
what he's trying to say is like it's not
going to be work because she wouldn't be
that energy around him
she's neutralizing it
she would have a different energy with
the right person that's what he's trying
to say so he's saying it's not going to
be he's not going to try and battle
where he's going to be masculine against
that's not what he's going to try and do
she's going gonna naturally just
like it's a film where you just
naturally bring it down and it's not a
thing where i'm gonna now go back he's
not gonna be about at home that's what
he's trying to say
so you think so you see you see um
so you see
women
that are feminine yeah that don't battle
yeah yeah or masculine women that put up
a little bit of a battle or whatever
battle what what do you think men are
looking for generally
i mean every men's um they're what
they're looking for their preference is
different it just depends on what you
feel like dealing with or what you feel
like that's why you don't understand so
i got a question wait wait that's
serious that's why you don't understand
men i got a question what do you think
men prefer though what do you think we
prefer
majority of men prefer what you're
saying i hate where you're coming from
okay then why don't you why why don't we
why don't you give us what majority men
want though
come on man nobody come on germany
conversations
cause
you know how you said give us what what
us men prefer
if at the end of the day you're gonna
have to fall for someone you're not
gonna be single for your life so you
could you're gonna look for the feminine
you are but if you're gonna if you're
not gonna find a feminine one guess what
you're gonna have to find someone here
let me let me let me let me land as well
let me tell you something i'll
understand that you want someone i might
as well go with i'm not homosexual i
might as well go over man okay if i'm
gonna bathe a masculine woman there's
men like i said the general ash gets it
and i think i even think you get it do
you know what i'm saying i think you
actually you do you actually get it hang
around
i know you men i don't even think the
men behind the camera again what you're
doing right
no
behind the camera oh they say no
are you the superman though are you that
guy wait wait wait let's calm it down
calm it down calm down calm it down calm
down calm it down calm it down
i think men
have become so used to yeah masculine
women yeah
that now
they are
accommodating
the traits
of masculine women
what it is is that the women of this
generation hang on guys behind the
camera hang on
the women of this generation have become
so masculine yeah for so long that men
have started to accommodate
mass masculine women and like i said at
the end of the day when all is said and
done and when the dust settles and the
smoke clears
masculine women in general respect
masculine men however they need to
understand that if they are in their
masculine
they're not going to attract
the masculine men because like like ash
said masculine and masculine don't
attract unless you're a homosexual right
that's the bottom line the masculine
masculine don't attract unless you're a
homosexual clearly i'm not that
masculine then
clearly i'm not
you said yourself in the relationship
that you had previous
that you felt like the man
so the man you got with was a feminine
man
so so the man that you got with was a
feminine man no right so yes and we were
speaking about this yesterday masculine
women tend to attract feminine men they
tend to go with feminine men because
there are because masculine and feminine
attract one another i understand you
know what is a hundred percent
understand where you're coming from
you know what yeah it comes out one
thing
let me ask you something about earlier
this might seem [ __ ] so
let me ask you a question do you think
that i get
into well you don't know i don't know
your life do you think that
would you assume
that i get into a lot of confrontations
with men
um
i would say that if a man did get into a
confrontation with you i would say that
it would be more of a battle than it
would be with a feminine woman so do you
think i'm not saying that you get into a
lot of them because i wouldn't know
so
are you married
no
do you have a girl
not at this moment
why not because i was in a 10-year
relationship i recently broke up with my
through a 10-year relationship
all right cool
can i ask you why it ended
what's that suit the conversation
because it might play into toxic
masculinity or femininity there was
there was nothing to do with toxic
masculinity or toxic feminine here's a
reason why it broke up cool
so
cool so i'm interested in why when when
it came to my
death this is this is where this
statement is yeah this is where it
really lands to you it's sent to me
because
i need it we're talking about
first we we had to talk we had to take
out whoever is beneath
the the level of
men that um females are attracted to
right we're talking about them the level
of men that that they're attracted to
that percentage that they they didn't
want to say the numbers in it but it was
you know we do the numbers that we're
talking about we know we know what type
of men they're talking about anyway
the five eight no no they ain't talking
about superman superman unfortunately
superman are on a another level because
listen because you're basically saying
that average level that you're talking
about may not be able to handle some of
my blackberry which is something that i
do agree with right however if all men
were then
supermen right if you are able to handle
beth basically the same woman that
you're also able to handle and maybe not
be able to have the time
the person you don't want to handle you
might not want to handle a level like
beth
a superman though can handle someone
like beth and then also handle someone
like
miss i don't know your name miss i don't
know your name
no matter what whatever level if let's
if we were to say that beth is at the
top level of masculinity right no matter
every level beneath though a superman
however not every man is a superman
though that's what the problem that's
what it is do you understand that even
saying that a woman is at a top level of
masculinity it's not attractive
like do you even understand that that is
just not true
you know what even that says to me why
am i the top level though
that was never my intention of living i
was not meant to be a man nor am i meant
to display
um
and
i i i genuinely believe yeah that us as
humans we have a
everyone has a balance of feminine and
masculine energy that you can tap into
right so you'll find
extreme versions of them so you'll find
extreme um feminine men and you'll find
extreme feminine women
me personally i don't believe i'm an
extreme no i mean masculine woman i
don't believe i'm an extreme masculine
woman truly i don't and if you know me
you know but i feel like
in terms of this
all right let's let's get back into it
this is what i'm saying from the start
how do we solve this toxic feminism
because
because me with india i feel like when
it comes to
okay cool when it comes to displaying my
femininity
i i genuinely don't believe that it's
toxic what did the other women have no
idea
before we get into that
a bunch of stupid super chats came in
while you were speaking so we're going
to read that we're going to read that
keep talking you'll get your book right
i'm telling you um so
money
so tim the roof had a 20 super chat um
i make money with my real job
not to be on a podcast and not learn
nothing without
being in a field learning how things are
down
okay
being oh sorry being out in the field
where things are how things are down tim
the roof again a hundred dollars big up
yourself tim they've got tips
the biggest hater in the yard salt
clothes 100.00
this little girl in the middle who looks
like someone from the matrix
who thinks they are someone
pear is a boss she understand she learns
i feel sad for her that she had to act
ice to you and have you
on i guess her podcast this money is for
pearl not for you okay he said his
money's repaired
um dragon stallion uh ten dollars
masculine
hang on guys please
masculine female and masculine male in a
relationship will end up with the male
in the position because the 304
isn't gonna stop fighting when she
should
tim the roof again twenty dollars i am
ion sorry i did that already
uh
i think yeah hang on i make money with
my real job not to be on a podcast yeah
okay tim the ruth again twenty dollars
all females in the room stay away from
this mind
thought from this woman in the middle
she's not the path of happiness in your
life her ideology is so wrong
not
also not nice
nice from the last chat stupid or
correct okay yeah i get you i'll get you
tim don't worry we got you is it all
correct thank you um
90 fruit or pie
uh 9.99
all of all of you need
all of you except the red shirt need to
listen
beautifully
allow it allow it
all of you except the red shirt yeah
uh need to listen to patrice o'neill
black phillips show episode 1 to 13 on
youtube girl in the middle is a bear she
needs a bear hunter to handle
her uh
chris listen i'm calm down you know
people that are tapped
out hang on guys we've got the super
chats guys seriously chris channel uh
ten dollars femininity isn't conditional
saying you're masculine until an
appropriate male is present is like a
man saying he only makes money if a
woman is around beth dominated a beta
but it failed long term
better gents podcast 20
this is simple the supermen want super
women and a woman
is her most super when she is fully
feminine
just like the superman is in his most
masculine
men and women are not the same courtney
harris
superman wants lois lane not the hulk
it's simple
two dollar super chat
90 fruit or pie 4.99
women want their cake and eat it too
they always want the option to change
their mind you will never get a yes or a
no with a qualifying statement
dragon stallion one thousand and one ten
dollars a person does not change their
energy around other people they are what
they are 24 7 365 and they will not
change it when they find the quote
unquote right person
90 fruit up by 4.99
men as predators have to worry about
other predators hunters etc why should
women have to get grief warm
sorry why should men have to get grief
from his woman humble thyself
boss
boss is the last super jack balls 10
pounds
she acts masculine
but it's all a front
she just seems like an attention seeker
and a drama queen also super chat money
is for pearl
you're on the bus home to your parents
house broth
[Music]
i think
and i think that concludes the super
chat
also guys i think that concludes today's
episode
um because yeah yeah you're saying can i
respond to the no no we're going to
conclude the episode because it's
actually quite late um before we
actually go thank you all for thank you
all for coming i appreciate it um i know
we got dicey and i know we've got spicy
that's how it gets but before we go can
you tell people where to find you oh you
can find me at the censor podcast
hosted by me and
myself
say your name
yeah you can also find medicine to
podcast you can also find me at
milan.sophia
but yeah this is the podcast
my name is ashley duran i'm an actor you
can find me on ad official with a xero
on all socials tick tock instagram and
snapchat thank you yeah i'm beth next
door i appreciate everyone who came in
to listen today don't mind me you don't
know me so don't act like you do i'm
beth next door i've got bnd visuals 101
and i've got teenage fever101 and then
make sure you follow my brothers to the
left and the right of me come on it's
called train artist
host newest
2022 artist newcomer um hey
more to say follow me
instagram
instagram is g h o s t underscore
c-o-l-t-r-a-n-e
that's ghost underscore call train
follow the thing man check out man ep
find me on instagram and tick tock at
nandy
sci and you all better follow me
at sarah garvey on all social medias
okay
as a matter of fact and my name is just
pearly things as a matter of fact since
just pearly things um shout out to just
purdy things living it up in miami and
my alter ego is now out in miami living
it up making videos that go viral um
thank you all for tuning in we shall see
you the next time
peace
hey